Você sabia que existe um fator de risco
cardíaco que afeta 1,5
bilhão de pessoas no mundo? É mais
perigoso que o colesterol alto e a
maioria dos médicos simplesmente não
mede? Uma metaanálise de 2025 com mais
de 145.000 vi participantes mostrou que
as estatinas, aquele remédio que tanta
gente toma pro colesterol, não faz
absolutamente nada contra esse vilão. Na
verdade, pode até piorar a situação em
alguns casos. Hoje eu vou te mostrar o
que é a lipoproteína A, por que que ela
é tão perigosa e quais são as opções de
tratamento, incluindo comentários sobre
cinco novas drogas que estão em fase
final de testes e ainda não sabemos se
vão de fato revolucionar o tratamento ou
se vão simplesmente acrescentar muitos
efeitos colaterais ainda não previstos.
Olha,
antes de continuar, eu preciso te contar
uma coisa que me deixa genuinamente
frustrado. Eu atendo pacientes a
praticamente 30 anos e o número de
pessoas que chegam no meu consultório
sem nunca terem ouvido falar de
lipoproteína A é realmente assustador.
Semana passada mesmo eu atendi um
executivo de 52 anos, infartou do nada,
segundo ele. LDL controlado, pressão
boa, não fumava, fazia exercício. Quando
eu pedi o exame de LPA, deu 180
nanomoles por litro, muito, muito
elevado. Ninguém tinha medido antes. Ele
ficou revoltado e com razão. Estamos
falando de um exame que custa menos de
R$ 100, que você precisa fazer uma única
vez na vida, porque os níveis são
geneticamente determinados e não mudam e
que pode literalmente salvar sua vida.
Mas a medicina ortodoxa muitas vezes
simplesmente ignora. Então vamos começo.
O que diabos é a lipoproteína A? Pensa
comigo. Você provavelmente ouve falar do
LDL, o famoso colesterol ruim. A
lipoproteína A ou LPA, como a gente
chama, é como se fosse o primo malvado
do LDL. é uma partícula parecida com
LDL, mas com adicional perigoso, uma
proteína chamada apolipoproteína A
grudada nela. Então, lipoproteína é uma
coisa e apolipoproteína A é outra.
Então, a LPA na sua composição tem a
apolipoproteína agregada. E essa
proteína adicional faz toda a diferença.
Ela carrega fosfolipídeos oxidados que
promovem inflamação aterosclerose e
formação de coágulos. Então, é uma
combinação tripla mortal. E aqui está o
problema diferente do colesterol comum
que você consegue controlar com dieta,
exercício e medicamentos. A LPA é 70 90%
determinada pela genética, pelos seus
genes. Isso mesmo. Não adianta correr
maratona, comer brócolis todo dia ou
tomar estatina. Se você herdou genes que
produzem LP alta, você vai ter LP alta,
ponto final. E é por isso que tantos
pacientes ficam frustrados e muitos
cardiologistas também ficam, porque eles
não têm um remédio muito efetivo para
isso. Os pacientes fazem tudo certinho,
o LDL baixa, mas o risco cardíaco
persiste. Agora, quanto é considerado
alto? Vou te dar os números. Anota aí.
Abaixo de 30 mg dl ou 75 nanomoles por L
é considerado desejável. entre 30 e 50
mg dil é limítrofe, já merece atenção. E
acima de 50 já é elevado. Acima de 70 é
muito elevado e coloca você em risco
significativo para infarto, AVC e até
calcificação da válvula órtica. Se você
fez o exame veio em nanomoles por litro,
é só dividir por 2,5 para ter uma ideia
aproximada em miligram por dclilro. Bem,
tá, doutor, mas se é genético e nada
funciona, por que que eu deveria me
preocupar? Ótima pergunta. É aqui que as
coisas ficam interessantes. Primeiro,
porque existem sim algumas opções que
funcionam parcialmente hoje. Segundo,
porque estamos vivendo uma revolução.
Pelo menos nós pensamos que seja há
cinco drogas novas em fase três de
testes e os resultados começam a sair já
nesse ano de 2026. Então, estamos
literalmente às portas de uma nova era
no tratamento cardiovascular. Esperemos
isso. Vamos falar do que funciona hoje
dentro de uma abordagem que eu trabalho,
que é a abordagem funcional integrativa.
A niaacina, que é a vitamina B3, B de
bola 3 em doses terapêuticas, é o único
tratamento tradicional com evidência de
redução da LPA. Houve uma metaanálise
2025 com 147 estudos e mais de 145.000
pessoas que foi demonstrado a Nacina
reduz a LPA em média 37%. cerca de 7 mg
por dcl. Isso é significativo. E qual
que seria o problema? É o sintoma ruim
que muitas vezes acompanha o uso na
niaacina, que é o flush. É um calorão no
rosto que incomoda muita gente, mas
existe formas de liberação prolongada
que minimizam isso e tomar uma aspirina
meia hora antes também ajuda. Outro
suplemento promissor é licarnitina. Uma
metaanálise publicada na Nature
Scientific Reports mostrou redução média
de quase 9 mg dcl nos liv n livros de
LPA. Parece pouco, mas para quem está
com níveis limítrofes pode fazer a
diferença. A dose estudada foi de 1 a 2
g por dia, vi oral. A coenzima Kés
também aparece nos estudos com uma
redução modesta de cerca de 3,5 mg dl. E
o interessante é que ela funciona melhor
justamente em quem tem LPA mais elevado,
ou seja, quem mais precisa é quem mais
se beneficia. E tem um bônus, coisas
ajuda na função mitocondrial e
hidotelial, então você ganha em várias
frentes. A dose que eu costumo
recomendar é de 100 a 200 mg por dia,
preferencialmente na forma ubiquinol,
que é a forma reduzida e a forma mais
bem absorvida. Um ponto importante que
pouca a gente sabe, existe uma sinergia
interessante quando você combina esses
suplementos.
Um estudo com pacientes hemodiálise
mostrou que a combinação de carnitina
com cozema Q10 teve efeito superior ao
uso isolado. É a velha história. Na
bioquímica raramente uma substância
trabalha sozinha. Agora, se você está em
risco alto, os inibidores de PCSK9,
como Evolvolocumab
e o Alirocumabem
a LPA em cerca de 27%.
Não é uma redução dramática, mas
combinada com a redução brutal que fazem
no LDL, pode ser uma ferramenta valiosa
para alguns pacientes selecionados. Mas
vamos comentar sobre as novas drogas.
temos cinco em desenvolvimento avançado
e os resultados aparentemente são
impressionantes se não houver pegadinhas
escondidas aí o pela carc da Novartes é
o mais avançado. É uma injeção mensal
reduz LPA em até 92%. O estudo LPA
horizon acompanha mais de 8.000
pacientes com doença cardiovascular
estabelecida e LP acima de 70 mg dcl. Os
resultados desfechos cardiovasculares
devem sair no primeiro semestre de 2026.
Esse vai ser o primeiro estudo da
história nos dizer definitivamente se
reduzir o LPA realmente vai prevenir
infartos. E é o marco, estamos todos de
olho. O Opaciran da AMGEN é uma injeção
a cada 12 semanas que reduz LPA em mais
de 95%.
Resultados são esperados para ano que
vem, 2027. O lepodisiranda erilili é
ainda mais impressionante, uma injeção
semestral que reduzpa em 97%.
O estudo acompanha quase 17.000
pacientes. É o maior estudo de LPA já
realizado com resultados previstos para
2029. E aí que vem a grande surpresa, o
MVLAPLIM
também da Elil Lili, que é um
comprimido, um tratamento oral.
Finalmente, nada de injeções, nada de ir
ao hospital para tomar esses remédios
que provavelmente vão ser caríssimos. Um
comprimido por dia e pronto, reduz LPA
em até 86% com efeito visível já nas
primeiras 24 horas. O estudo Kraken
mostrou que 97% dos pacientes atingiram
níveis adequados de LPA. O estudo de
fase três com mais de 10.000 pacientes
está em andamento com resultados
esperados para 2031. Mas olha, se o
Pelacarcen ou Opaziran mostrarem
benefício nos estudos de 26 e 27, a
aprovação de todas essas drogas deve ser
acelerada. Então o que que você faz
enquanto essas drogas não chegam ao
mercado? Primeiro faça o exame, peça ao
médico para medir a lipoproteína A. Se
ele não conhecer, troque de médico.
Brincadeira, não tô brincando, mas não
muito, né? Segundo, se estiver elevada,
otimize todos os outros fatores de
risco. Baixe o LDL ao máximo, controle a
pressão, controle a glicemia. Terceiro,
converse sobre niacina, pode ser
niaacina de liberação lenta também para
não dar o flush. E suplementação com com
enzima Q10 e el cararnitina. Quarto,
considere os inibidores de PCSK9
se você se encaixar num perfil de
altíssimo risco. E quinto, fique de
olho, já estamos em 2026 e pode ser esse
o ano que muda tudo na cardiologia. Se
não der, grandes efeitos colaterais.
Vamos torcer para que não haja. Saia do
vídeo agora. Se você gosta de ficar no
superficial, eu vou contar uma verdade
conveniente. A plataforma aqui e o
conselho me limitam. Aqui eu preciso
simplificar, censurar dosagem, omitir
protocolos controversos. Sobre a LPA,
por exemplo, não posso falar abertamente
sobre as dosagens exatas de linhacina
que eu uso na clínica, as combinações
específicas de suplementos e os
fenótipos genéticos que respondem
melhor. Na comunidade fechada não tem
esse filtro. Eu compartilho os
protocolos que eu uso na minha clínica,
incluindo o protocolo completo para LPA.
com dosais precisas, fornecedores
confiáveis e monitoramento adequado.
Também falamos de casos de reversão que
pareciam impossíveis, combinações ao
fabb que funcionam, interpretação vçada
de exames. Então é basicamente ter
acesso ao meu cérebro médico sem
intermediários em lives semanais em que
respondemos perguntas, PDF com 47
protocolos exclusivos e um grupo
maravilhoso no WhatsApp com pessoas
fantásticas. Se você quer a visão
funcional real, sem simplificação para
massas, clique, seja membro. Não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.
Agora, se você quer ainda mais fundo,
existe o nível dois. Cada duas semanas
temos lives de imersão total com até 2
horas de duração, desse artigo
científico linha por linha, como os
últimos estudos sobre terapias genéticas
para lipar, que a maioria dos médicos
ainda não conhece, ouviu falar.
Debatemos controvérsias que ninguém usou
tocar, revelamos os bastidores das
pesquisas que a indústria não quer que
você entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos. No final, como
agradecimento, você torna parte visível
dessa comunidade de elite que está
reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará ao meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade, tendo o seu
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. E não
é só sobre aprender, é sobre pertencer
ao círculo interno de quem está mudando
o jogo. Poucos têm essa coragem. Será
que você tem? Já que estamos falando de
risco cardíaco e artérias, você precisa
conhecer os oito alimentos que danificam
suas artérias. Assista esse vídeo aqui
que vai complementar perfeitamente o que
você aprendeu hoje sobre como proteger o
seu coração. Agradecimentos especiais
aos nossos membros queridos dos estudos
avançados na comunidade fechada do
YouTube. Começando pelos novos membros
que entraram recentemente, Coruja
Curiosa, Walter Salgado, Luciano Silva
Polinelli, Luciano Elias, Carlos Rovi,
Odonor Pinheiro, Cíntia de Assis
Oliveira, Jorge Cabral e Fernando
Machado. Sejam muito, muito bem-vindos.
Agradeço também aos membros que fizeram
upgrade pros estudos avançados. Coruja
Curiosa, Irma LC, Iana Medicina,
Adriane BMS, Dr. Ana Paula Rodrigues,
José Fortunato Murtinho, Sou Jucioli,
Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril, Estela
Mari Silva, Elô Terapias Integrativas e
Luís Anselmo Neves. Obrigado pela
confiança e elevar o nível de
participação. Um abraço especial aos
membros que retornaram à comunidade,
Alex Caldas, Marcelo Pimentel e Cláudio
Leitão. Que bom ter vocês de volta. Eu
quero fazer um reconhecimento especial
aos membros mais fiéis. Estela Mares com
57 meses de fidelidade, Dra. Ana Paula
com 45 meses, Marcelo Pimentel com 23 e
Elô Terapia Integrativas com 9 meses de
história conosco. A todos vocês eu
agradeço de coração pelo apoio
prestrado. Vocês fazem diferença nessa
comunidade.